[Musik]
willkommen beim ein video arbeitet
erkenntnis von an der videoqualität ich
habe mir neue kammer gold und zwar seine
frau nie ganz einfach aus dem grund ich
habe vor in zukunft öfter zu bloggen
genauso auf wie das jetzige video was
heißt folgt auf jeden fall kam er vor
ungefähr zwei wochen meine pizza video
online wo ich wirklich eine woche nur
pizza gegessen habe das ist auch echt
krass die ral gegangen kann man also
sagen also das ist ziemlich gut
angekommen natürlich es gab auch viele
die gesagt haben fällt oder diskutiert
haben das kann man nicht als real sein
so übrigens opfer hier nur noch die hier
gibt es auch ein deutsches online link
einfach mal oben in der video
beschreibung das den caps aus meinem
virtue und ihr falsches thema auf jeden
fall wenn ich mir schon so zwölf oder
dreizehn vierzehn kauf wird man sieht ja
welche video die abgekauft danet jochen
auf oder also ich kann euch zu 100
prozent versichern ich habe wirklich nur
pizza gegessen bis auf das eine oder
keine ahnung vielleicht ein apfel war
glaube ich auch noch mal dabei aber das
war's halt sonst war es wirklich nur
pizza und eigentlich habe ich gedacht
das wird eine einmalige sache sein
aber unter diesen videos den so viele
kommentare als spitzel macht doch mal
mit süßigkeiten das war glaube ich der
top kommentar alex bitte macht das mal
damit und damit und ich hab mir gedacht
ich habe heute heißen und körperlich
erkannt was jetzt zu machen kann was
ausprobieren jetzt einfach mal zu
versuchen eine woche nur süßigkeiten zu
essen ich habe mich jetzt nur wochen
wieder echt gesund ernährt sich gesund
eigentlich habe ich mir zugedacht
man kann vom ausflug nicht meint die
nächste woche stehen wieder viel an
das ganze wird auf jeden fall geblockt
und dabei endlich halt nur süßigkeiten
oder versuchst erstmal was ich aber
sofort am anfang sagen muss leute es
kann sein dass ich nach zwei tagen schon
sage etwas funktioniert nicht dann werde
ich jetzt auch im tiefen lesen anzeige
ich auf jeden fall den titel abbruch
oder sonstwas und wäre es halt einfach
unfertigen über die wirklich zu sehen
wollen er will eine woche nur
süßigkeiten essen der muss das auch
durchziehen
wir schauen mal in dem video soll es
eigentlich mehr um diesen block gehen
ich werde öfter mal flogen und ich hoffe
ihr seid arbeit ja dann will ich gar
nicht lange weiter umlagern in den
kommentaren auch öfter mal erlebt auch
mal eine woche wegen seiner damals bock
drauf habt da hätte ich auch persönlich
war es bock drauf lag man noch nach oben
oder schreibt kommentare
jetzt geht's erst mal schlafen also wir
sehen uns auf jeden fall morgen
jetzt habe ich noch dieses lasse jetzt
auch sein
guten morgen ich hab sie uns schon
geschlafen rein völlig aber beginne in
die uni
und was geht so flüchtig wie schokolade
oder wein natürlich will man die bahn
verpasst
wenn wir die bayern ja firma verfassen
dann bin ich aber wieder leute das
wetter ist auf jeden fall heftig
dementiert und verschüttet tasche gehabt
meinte ganzen morgen
[Musik]
ich mache eine 70 leute wissen zu dumm
wir haben einfach schon javi varas
sie frühstücken ich glaube dass wir erst
mal so bleiben uni dann gar nicht mehr
so sehr vom export offensive sein wie
fest das war drei tage vielleicht klappt
ja und wenn es sinn macht das weiter zu
wenig geschehen nicht gelten
das passt in die wüste so leuchtet auch
im ernst sein
ich brauche gar nichts war mit schmeckt
gut bei uns war
wir haben sicher so warmen fünf tranchen
mit vollmond ist man nicht auf jeden
fall gehen jetzt nach hause wann geht's
nach hause übrigens und meinen eltern
und morgen abend auf dem kurs konzert da
nehme ich auch nicht und ist ein
traumpass keinen spaß am einkaufen in
hall mit den geistlichen nach einer
woche weiter grabmal video geplant was
heute noch online kommt daher hatte ich
nie welchen ganz auf jeden fall was
machen wir jetzt noch
drei länder auf jeden fall nicht erst
duschen dann video gedreht dann
wirklichkeiten einkauft und dann geht's
morgen massiver nach hause zurück die
linken 12 geschlagen können freund
gleich mal ein kurzes hauptstory haare
werden erst nach hinten gemacht dann
nehmen so schaumfestiger sagt ihr denn
meine haare dann kann man auch ganz
normal finden kämen eher konstant
eingelegt ist dann kommt da noch was
drauf und dann stehen die darauf erstmal
ein gummibärchen so weise es ist ihre
zwar heute und ich habe den kopf trifft
ich denke das kommt vom wetter aber
vielleicht kann ich mein ich abbrechen
einziges mal fällt morgen vier pick ups
oder halt diese fälschungen davon und
eine halbe packung haribo und ja bald
schon wieder hunger deswegen wir gegen
euch auf jeden fall einkaufen werden es
schon früher abend aber schluss noch zu
sehen dass ich mein video fertig und das
ist online geht also wir sehen uns die
leute was klappt ich hoffe ihr seht mich
gerade auf jeden fall vielleicht ist
hier besser lebt auf jeden fall ich hab
einfach weil ich mich drüber geschlafen
als solcher von rechen schlafen geht
erst mal einkaufen dabei gesagt ich hole
märz richtig krass tätigkeit also ich
muss sagen ich habe mich in letzter zeit
wenig dieses kleinen gesten und ich
freue mich jetzt mal wieder richtig
zuzuschlagen und und spaß in der nichts
vernünftiges gelten übrigens an dieser
stelle mal flecken aus hier alex wie
richtigkeit der video beschreibung zu
sehen was hier zu finden
gibt es trotzdem die kosten die knebelt
um ehrlich zu sein ich super kinder die
sonst irgendwie da geben aber keine
ahnung wo das ganze so aus da geht auch
in sein haus hat jetzt nochmal melka und
1 sollte erstmal für jetzt also beispiel
sagen ich habe mir jahrhundert zwar
nicht unbedingt ausschließlichkeit aber
mit rechts auf jeden fall essen
[Musik]
also ich weiß auf jeden fall war ich mal
schießen kann
corny oder halt make up kann ich doch
gar nicht so ungesund auf jeden fall
muss jetzt auch noch schlafenden mega
müde
bis morgen leute was geht morgen damals
gerade glaube ich musste schon weil die
band um gleich ok ich hab' noch 10 mio
auf jeden fall 840 ich mir morgens zur
uni und ich fahre von dort dann sofort
nach hause
deswegen muss sich jetzt alles in meinem
rucksack liegen ich hab mir gedacht habe
komme auch ein paar von euch lieben
konzert deswegen nehme ich mal fragt von
diesem märz sachen mit und verschränkt
die provinz war gespannt habe ich alle
süßigkeiten mickrige wird es jetzt noch
rein und die teile nur wenn wir voll mit
wasser kann man auch linke mit 9 und die
kepplinger nach oben drauf
die frage brauche ich mit die straße
abgesperrt da aus reiste die baden nein
ich habe jetzt uni fertig auf jeden fall
an die die mich mal fragen warum ich
studiere blätter setzen sich viele
gefragt einfach aus dem grund weil ich
bisschen weiter denke ich hat auf jeden
fall nach hause und raucht trinkt was zu
essen
ich habe da diese geilenkirchen genau
wegen der ungewissheit habe ich internet
viele so viele gefragt warum ich
studiere so dass youtube bislang nicht
genug hatte sich heinze gibt so viele
youtuber sie nicht studieren weil sie
einmal sie plötzlich fünfstellig
verloren und ehrlich zum teil jubelsturm
nächste station
[Musik]
im endspiel träfe die falschen zu hause
war wieder stressig züge wie immer
überfüllt der eine typ hat die ganze
zeit meine plätzchen ist auf jeden fall
durch schnell geht erstmals meine schule
weil wir haben das alle eintragen dann
hätte ich aber nicht mit und dann geht's
los zum konzert wir sehen uns spieler
und wegen eigentlich echt voll gut so
meine ich hab hier korn und eine packung
mehl komplett vergessen
geil alter alben leute was geht ab disco
wir fahren jetzt nach so keine an habe
das kind auf jeden fall ein guter
kollege von mir hat ein konzert musik
das heute anschauen
ich habe auch bei cnet gepostet dass ich
da bin deswegen denkt ein paar von euch
werden auch dabei und koala
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt hier hindurch von meyer
die
[Applaus]
[Musik]
roger waters ist wir kommen ja viel
marlene besser passte sehr gut die wir
nicht drauf
[Musik]
ich weiß jetzt dahin aber klopp würde
nicht das ganz richtig keine verletzten
ist das wichtig
[Musik]
die leute wissen was aber es wird knapp
kurz ausfallen als alle sich verkaufen
nun schneller niveau und noch schneller
effektiver die wache wurden gestern
spontan noch feiern gegangen und mir
geht's morgen dementsprechend auch nicht
so gut auch dass die ernährung angeht
nicht so gut aber so schlecht jetzt mir
auch nicht hab ja gestern wirklich ich
hab so viele süßigkeiten geschenkt
bekommen ich kann euch dass er gleich
mal zeigen und die reichen jetzt erstmal
die frage ist halt nur hätte das weiß
ich verpasse und die besondere lage auch
geschenkt bekommen auf jeden fall
schließlich beruht darauf gestanden mit
aufgefallen
ich habe die hälfte vergessen als ich
auf eine tüte mitgenommen aber ich habe
noch nicht bekommen wo ich eigentlich
den rest alles angetan habe das heißt
wir haben jetzt hier also das ist auf
jeden fall auch eine menge
das ist erstmal das wichtig für kinder
neu und in villach erklärte wichtig
seien
paris werde ich das vergessen dann bin
ich gerne noch mehr stärken ich wirklich
so gerne einfach von familien hätten
aber zum kindertag ist auch okay dass
leute was geht ab ich bin hier gerade
unten um fans zu sein habe ich absolut
kein bock mehr ich engagiert das zweite
nutzer 21 habe ich zum frühstück
gegessen
die schuhkartons packung liegt auch
schon leer eben war fußball dran und ich
hab's katrin 200 gramm enthält circa 34
stück drei habe ich mein bruder gegeben
dass ein 30 stück habe ich selber gästen
heute erzählt zum beispiel literatur war
echt mal in kohlers weg für
zwischendurch der mich so ein bisschen
an normal frühstück erinnert aber der
rest halt wirklich überhaupt nicht also
für das blatt zufolge ein teller nudeln
essen und das ist absolut gesund bin mal
gespannt wie sie morgen früh geht aber
eines kann ich sagen ich freue mich
jetzt auf meine kinder zu löschen
mal sehen wie oft ich in den kommentaren
lesebücher wertvoll wenn du bitte gebt
euch das hier alle auf einmal alles leer
und helfern du dich dazu jetzt gebt euch
diese geniale frucht und der letzte
echte heute ein kinderzeit gesponsert
von einer lieben zuschauerin irgendwie
schmecken die anders öffnet sich ihr
fragt euch wahrscheinlich es in den
kommentaren warum wird alex wichtig ich
weiß es selber nicht aber ich werde
einfach nicht dick ich kann essen was
ich will spaß auch wenn es hier echt
sehr sehr gerne wieder mal ein teller
nudeln sein kann also aber ich schaue
mir vielleicht jetzt wieder gut und wenn
es mir gut geht warum ich etwas weiter
ist man muss aber auch mal bedenken ich
habe ja gesagt vielleicht habe ich nur
drei seiten wir haben heute obwohl er
von montagabend auf dienstagabend mit
zur am donnerstag am ist jetzt gerade
deswegen drei tage habe ich schon krass
schönen guten morgen du schöne stadt ich
schon mein video bestimmen das kommt das
gleich online also mit freitag wie
geht's nicht so gut aber auch uns
vielleicht also etwas kennt wieder
normal hätten
da muss ich auf meine mama last things
hat in dieser woche einen schon so viel
süßigkeiten gegessen wie in den letzten
zwei monaten zusammen nicht mal nicht so
gut aus meiner haut eigentlich geht das
nicht ich habe irgendwie einen coolen
körper also ich kann essen was ich will
sagt geht erstmal duschen dann guck mal
[Musik]
leute das wetter ist ja irgendwie
richtig schlecht ist gar nicht mal so
warm und es hatte gerade einfach übers
gewittert auf jeden fall weit genug wird
sagen hier hast du schon gesehen ich
habe jetzt gar zum frühstück und
mittagessen und beendete somit das
wochen experiment beziehungsweise diesem
blog hat auf jeden fall eine menge spaß
gemacht so viele süßigkeiten zu essen
und zu probieren und natürlich hat es
denn auch nachteile
was auf schmerzen und so angeht aber so
schlimm war es nicht ich will jetzt
einfach gern aufhören weil ich morgen
anstrengenden tag hat und somit
eigentlich nährstoffe braucht deswegen
hoffe ich hatte ein bisschen
unterhaltung das noch nach oben da
wirklich mega freien sex hatte das ist
auf jeden fall ab und wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder